البدايه باخر التطورات والانباء العاجله
من ايران حيث اكدت الدفاع الايرانيه
واعترفت وقوعه هجوم بمسيرات على مصنع
للذخيره في اصفهان وقالت ان الدفاعات
الجويه تصدت لهذا الهجوم كان هناك بيان
لوزاره الدفاع قالت فيه بانه نفذ مساء يوم
امس قرابه منتصف الليل هجوم وصفته
بالفاشل باستخدام مسيرات على احد همم
مجمعات الورش التابعه لوزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه وقالت انه لحسن الحظ
وبالاجراءات التي وصفتها باحترازيه
والدفاعيه تم استهداف احدى هذه الطائرات
المسيره من قبل الدفاعات الجويه نشاهد احد
الانفجارات في هذا الموقع الان على الشاشه
يضيف البيان انه وقعت اثنتان من الطائرات
في ما وصفته شباك الدفاعات
وانفجرتات ولم تقع اصابات ولحقت اضرار
قالت بانها طفيفه بسقف الورشه الامر الذي
لم يعطل معدات و مهام المجمع على كل حال
هذا البيان يتحدث همم عن شيء ربما لا
يتطابق مع من شاهده في الصوره هناك
انفجارات بالفعل شاهدنا في صور اخرى همم
حرائق كانت اندلعت وايضا همم قال شهود
عيان اكدوا انهم سمعوا صوت طائرات مسيره
واشرنا الى هذا الامر في سياق نشراتنا
السابقه واكد ايضا انهم سمعوا صوت
الدفاعات الجويه هذا يتطابق ربما مع ما
جاء في بيان وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه ايضا
الانباء
اشاره الى ان هناك اصوات للانفجارات سمعت
فيها مدام وسمعت في كرج وفي قاعده نوجا لا
نعلم الى الان همم ما حقيقه اا هذه
الانباء وماذا كانت هذه الهجمات بالطائرات
المسيره متزامنه على مواقع عسكريه لكن
الان هناك تاكيد بان ما حدث ليس حادث
وانما هجوم ولو ان وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه
تؤكد الى الان بان الاضرار محدوده وانها
نجحت في تحيد الطائرات وانما نشاهده من
انفجارات على الشاشه سببه سقوط الطائرات
داخل هذه المنشاه العسكريه التابعه لوزاره
الدفاع او المصنع